this video is made possible by
brilliance you're gonna learn more about
brilliant later in today's video but if
you'd like to learn more about them
right now go to brilliant org forward
slash bio graphics you'll also find a
link in the description below Friedrich
Nietzsche was a 19th century philosopher
who is most remembered for his killer
quotes and incredibly large moustache
the main goal of his work was aimed to
uncover the fact that there is no
universal truth and that the human
condition is in a constant state of
overcoming our animalistic urges he came
up with many amazing quotes that we
still use to this very day including
what doesn't kill me makes me stronger
and of course God is dead while he is
often misunderstood and his work has
been used for the justification of evil
over the past hundred years the
philosophy of Friedrich Nietzsche truly
has changed the way that people in the
21st century live and today in the video
we're going to talk about his life his
philosophy and his legacy
Friedrich Nietzsche was born on October
15th 1844 in Saxony Prussia which is now
a part of modern-day
Germany he just happened to be born on
the same day as king friedrich wilhelm
of the fourth which is why his parents
decided to name him after their ruler he
grew up in a very strict Protestant
family his father was a priest and his
grandfather published books defending
Lutheranism his father contracted an
excruciating Lee painful brain disease
that lasted for a full year before he
finally died then in 18-49 Friedrichs
younger brother Ludvig also died when he
was only 2 years old by the time he
started going to kindergarten Nietzsche
had seen so much death and suffering in
his young life that he was already a
very serious person he was nearsighted
and he got constant headaches from a
condition called myopia therefore he
started wearing glasses as young Charles
he looked and acted like a tiny
professor who was far too grown-up for
childish games obviously this didn't
make him very popular with his
classmates and he did not make many
friends most of his childhood was spent
surrounded by women his mother his
grandmother and two aunts they all
shared in the responsibilities of
raising him in 1856 Friedrich Nietzsche
his sister Elisabeth and his mother
moved to their own house in Nonnberg
Germany that house would become the
place where he would write his most
important work and the property has been
preserved today as a museum nature
attended Christian prep school and later
transferred to a boarding school he
never got particularly good grades but
his father had a state job before he
passed away which meant that he got a
full scholarship to any college of his
choice he chose to study theology and
philosophy at Bond University he
originally wanted to become a priest
like his father but after just two
semesters he realized that his personal
beliefs were in direct conflict with the
theological curriculum and he often got
into arguments with his professors he
had to eventually transfer to the
University of Leipzig Andy started
studying ancient languages like Latin
and Greek as a students new trip
contracted syphilis from a prostitute at
a brothel which made him physically weak
and in constant pain for the rest of his
life syphilis is also known for causing
people to fall into madness which
ultimately did happen to him at that
time there was no cure for syphilis
today it's treated with penicillin but
that would not be invented until 1923
significantly after his death
spent much of his free time listening to
live performances of orchestras and
operas the music was so beautiful that
helped him to forget about his pain he
was particularly fascinated by the work
of composer Richard Wagner and he would
pay to see each new performance three or
four times in a row he was completely
inspired by the tragedy of the
characters in Vargas operas and he
eventually got to meet the composer they
became very good friends and Richard
Wagner was sort of like a father figure
to Nietzsche when he was 24 years old he
worked as a full-time professor of
languages at the University of Basel he
taught for several years even though he
claims that he was not all that happy in
the classroom he decided to volunteer
his time as an orderly at the hospital
after school however he ended up
contracting dysentery and diphtheria
from the patients his health continued
to decline so dramatically that he would
sometimes end up bedridden for several
days straight he decided to retire from
being a professor in his 30s and lived
on a very modest pension the nature
simply staying alive it was a constant
battle he spent a great deal of time in
bed with nothing to do and he was always
thinking about the meaning of life and
humanity this is when he began to write
books on philosophy
[Music]
Friedrich Nietzsche believed that there
is no absolute truth and that people
should not have blind faith in their
church or their political leaders today
this is kind of common sense but back in
the 1800s people were raised that there
were absolute right and wrong answers
and there was nothing in between there
was no gray by telling people to inquire
rather than just blindly accept
something he inspired future generations
do completely change the way that we
think one of his most famous quotes God
is dead is used by atheists everywhere
but it's actually misunderstood and
rather taken out of context what he
really said was God is dead God remains
dead and we have killed him how shall we
comfort ourselves the murderers of all
murderers he wasn't celebrating the
death of God though he was making a
statement the more and more people were
losing faith all the time and he
believed that without Christianity
mankind didn't know how to figure out
right and wrong without the existence of
religion people often looked up to their
political leaders and royal families
with a sort of god-like reverence he
knew that people needed something else
to take religions place he wanted people
to embrace arts like music literature
and theater instead and he said that
Shakespeare had just as much value to
human morality as the Bible without
giving away people's ability to think
for themselves he believed that the
rules of society were developed to keep
people down and maintain the status quo
for example in Christianity it's taught
that people should be like Jesus Christ
and not have a desire for material
things Nietzsche believed that this is
only taught to the poor in order to
manipulate them to accept their station
in life if people are taught to feel
shame for feeling envious of others and
desiring more they may not try to
achieve a higher status
therefore if they're happy with less
they won't cause a revolution against
their governments in order to demand
more Nietzsche tells us to embrace our
own selfish desires and that the rules
of society are something that need to be
overcome in order to get to the real
truth of our lives Nietzsche believed
that every individual person should be
in the process of zelfs Stobo Bing dong
or self overcoming if we are envious of
someone else this is just a sign of what
we
we need in order to become our true
selves for example if you feel envious
of guys who look muscular it's a sign
that you should go to the gym if you're
jealous if someone who is rich
you should find a job that makes more
money etc etc everyone has their own
dream and if we refuse to acknowledge
these desires we're only going to make
ourselves miserable and even if we fail
to achieve these goals at least we have
the satisfaction of knowing we tried
Nietzsche said that if someone has
succeeded in overcoming obstacles while
also accepting their failures with grace
they have become an uber man short
Superman
[Music]
he claims that every man should aspire
to become like this he said that most
people they're stuck in between their
animal instincts and the ubermensch and
there is a constant struggle between the
two impulses he was one of the first
people to come up with the concepts that
ignorance is bliss and that it's easy to
be happy as a human if you just accept
the status quo he admits that the quest
for knowledge and to become the
ubermensch might make him miserable
along the way but it was a life that he
chose to pursue nonetheless many people
have read of this concept of uber
mentioned misinterpreted it as to mean
the ability to become someone who is
superior to the rest of humanity others
like the Nazis would see this as proof
that certain races were more civilized
and therefore more human than others now
just before we get into his personal
life and his death as well as his legacy
I do want to take a moment to thank the
people who make this video possible
and that's brilliance now I know
mid-roll ads they're not great further
video here but these videos are long so
I sure hope you appreciate our need to
have some sponsors in order to make them
possible they're quite expensive to make
now brilliance are a learning platform
which teaches through something called
an active learning now like Nietzsche
said we should all question things and
the best way to do that is with a solid
understanding of the principles of well
anything and if you want to learn the
principles of science and beyond then
that's where brilliant comes in I don't
know if you've ever sat down with you
know some scientific textbook and going
through it you're reading it and then
you end up reading the same page six
times over and over again you still
don't really understand what I'm there
going on about you're just not taking it
in well that's something called passive
learning and brilliant they're not about
that at all brilliant solves this
problem with active learning they give
you something super short to read it's
usually just a few lines and then you
immediately apply it to a problem so you
really have to be engaged you just rinse
and repeat that and suddenly through a
few little problems you are
understanding stuff that you didn't
think you would be I've used brilliance
and I think you should go try it out
just to see how fascinating it is and
how quickly you can grasp the complex
subject you can support by graphics
they're going to brilliant org /pi
graphics and now let's get back to me
chat
even though friedrich nietzsche is a
household name today his work would not
be translated into other languages until
the 1890s and by that point he was
already too sick to enjoy his new
popularity so while his philosophy was
well known in germany he wasn't exactly
becoming rich and famous
in fact his philosophy made him very
unpopular and it ruined his friendship
with Richard Wagner Wagner indeed
thought that Nietzsche had gone mad
nature decided to isolate himself in the
Swiss Alps where he could spend a lot of
time in nature he often went on long
walks thinking of nothing but philosophy
only to go home and write his ideas down
ready for his next book he wrote several
volumes of his ideas and sometimes he
got letters in the mail from fellow
philosophers and people who wanted to be
as friends he met a psychoanalyst named
Lugh andreas salami when she read
Nietzsche's well actually felt that his
philosophy perfectly aligned with
everything she had already been thinking
she was only twenty years old at that
time but nature considered her to be his
protege Lew was also trying to challenge
the norms of society by experimenting to
see if men and women can truly be
friends without sex getting in the way
of a relationship in 1882 Nietzsche
decided to go on a year-long vacation to
Italy with Lew Andres Salome and their
mutual friends Paul ree-ree was also a
philosopher the three friends wanted to
buy an old monastery and start an
academic community gather so that they
could live in a society that was only
filled with other like-minded
intellectuals Friedrich Nietzsche he was
excited since he hopes that he could
finally have a group of friends who
understood him but his family they were
totally against the idea indeed his
sister Elisabeth was always writing him
letters telling him to stop trying to
make a cult there was also a bit of a
love triangle going on because Friedrich
and Paul were both in love with Lou and
they were competing to win her heart
Paul proposed to her first but she
rejected him saying that she liked him
enough for them to live together but
more like brother and sister she claimed
that sex got in the way of thinking
clearly and she used Nietzsche's own
philosophy saying that society demands
that women get married that she
personally wished to remain celibate and
focus on academic work even though he
agreed to be friends Friedrich Nietzsche
was still only human and the more he got
to know her the more he was falling in
love after all Lou seemed to be the only
woman on the planet who completely
understood his life's work
if
but she put him in the friendzone just
like Paul Reve in her defense Nisha did
have syphilis and marrying him would
have meant that she would have
contracted the disease as well but she
continued to live with him flirting
teasing and leading him on
he remained hopeful that she would
eventually come around and he proposed
to her two more times
no amounts of intellectual reasoning
could overcome his human desire in this
situation it became what you do
uncomfortable for the three of them his
dream of starting a comm unit never
happened and Lou and Paul rode away on
their horse-drawn carriage leaving
Friedrich behind it's probably best that
he got out of that situation though
because she later broke up with Paul
Ryan's married a man named Friedrich
Karl Andreas they apparently remained
celibate throughout the entire course of
their marriage she actually did have
sexual affairs though which is probably
just a little bit hypocritical she also
had an emotional affair with none other
than Sigmund Freud it turns out that
this was all one big experimenter and in
1910 she published a book called the
erotic where we learned that she spent
most of her life trying to analyze and
document the differences between men and
women when it came to sex
[Music]
the relationship with Lu Andres Salim a
completely traumatized Friedrich
Nietzsche and he never got married he
often wrote about love and how it can
make the most logical person feel like
they're going crazy
instead of writing about his own life
though Nietzsche expressed his feelings
in a book called thus Spoke Zarathustra
this is about a man who isolates himself
in the mountains and finds all of the
wisdom in the world but he can't find
any disciples to listen to or follow him
he then becomes the loneliest man in the
world since he was rejecting
Christianity Nietzsche knew that mankind
needed some sort of moral compass to
live by therefore he wrote Beyond Good
and Evil and addressed all of the issues
of what makes something good or bad in
1888 he could feel his mind and his body
betraying him his last book was called
the Antichrist where he expressed his
transvaluation of all values where he
was trying to come up with a set of
rules for morality that could replace
Christianity he saw himself as a martyr
who was making a sacrifice for the human
race in 1889 he was only 44 years old
and he had a nervous breakdown
he was triggered into hysteria when he
was walking in the streets of Turin in
Italy he saw a man beating a horse with
a whip and he ran to the horse hugged
its neck to protect it and he was
sobbing and saying I understand you
his landlord David Fino had to usher in
out of the street and get him back to
his room he spent the next two days
laying on a couch in a catatonic state
so FINA arranged for him to get home to
Basel in Germany even though they'd had
a falling-out Richard Wagner and his
wife they were still his true friends
they were the ones who got him help and
got him into a mental hospital during
one of the last moments where he was
responsive he started to sketch a
picture of a man and a woman hugging one
another in a long embrace before he
slipped into a permanent catatonic state
it was almost as if he was trying to say
that all of his philosophical work was
nothing without someone to share it with
and that at the end of his life love was
the one thing that he truly wanted more
than anything else the Oscars all he was
diagnosed with paralytic dementia which
was a direct result of his battle with
syphilis which had gone on for over 20
years but many people also believed that
the pressure he put on himself to find
the answer to morality without God and
to unravel the inner workings of the
human condition is what ultimately made
him go
see he slipped into madness and was
unresponsive when people tried to speak
to him he eventually died in the year
[Music]
soon after his death Friedrich
Nietzsche's work was being translated
into multiple languages and it began to
inspire people everywhere however many
people would read his work and
completely misinterpret what he was
trying to say even his sister Elizabeth
who was a pseudo Nazi later republished
a second edition of his books she
rewrote certain sections of his works to
glorify the German race as being
superior to the rest of the world
because of this nature has been blamed
for starting not just one but two world
wars before World War one even priests
were preaching Nietzsche's philosophy at
their pulpits relating it to their own
countries this caused a great deal of
national pride especially in Germany
Adolf Hitler he became a fan of neat
Sharon's he took this as a sign that the
Germans were far more evolved than the
rest of the human race during the rise
of the Third Reich in the 1930s fascists
often quoted Nietzsche especially with
his idea of the ubermensch
they wanted to make an entire race of
supermen Nietzsche sister welcomed out
of Hitler to the museum where they posed
together for a photograph next to the
bust of Friedrich Nietzsche even today
many critics of Nietzsche's work
consider his books to be too dangerous
for young people to read since his main
philosophy is to question everything
this can often manifest in acts of
rebellion in teenagers after all if they
question their teachers parents and
governments they are more likely to lash
out indeed in 1924 this happened in the
case of Leopold and Loeb they were two
college students in Chicago who thought
they were smarter than everyone else and
that they were the example of the
ubermensch that Nietzsche was writing
about they believed that they could
commit the perfect crime so they
murdered a 14 year old boy their defense
lawyer cited Nietzsche is the reason why
they committed the murder and yes it's a
ridiculous excuse because plenty of
people read Nietzsche and they don't
become serial killers but the jury they
bought it and those two young men got
away with murder because the jury
considered Nietzsche's philosophy to be
just that dangerous despite his
criticisms civilization of the 20th and
21st century has been completely changed
by Nietzsche's teachings and they
continue to change things to this very
day now it's very normal to think
critically and question the world around
us and it's often the basis of a liberal
arts education as for those of us who do
not go to church we tend to learn about
right and wrong from what we see on TV
and in the movies
whether we realize it or not we are
living in a very nietzsche a squirrel's
it's just a shame that he didn't live to
see it so I really hope you enjoyed the
video if you did please do give us a
thumbs up below also don't forget to
subscribe to this channel and check out
a brilliant link below and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]